Mr.
Vice President,
it is so nice to see you here in Kiev.
I know you met with President
Zelensky today.
You were in Butcher.
You were in urging
your fellow
Republican presidential candidates,
meantime, are in early primary states.
They're holding fundraisers.
Why does it matter to you to be here?
America's as the leader
of the free world.
Or the arsenal of democracy.
And from the very moment
that Russia engaged in this unprovoked
act of aggression,
invading a neighboring country,
I've strongly supported
American efforts
to give the Ukrainian fighters
what they need to fight and and win.
And I must tell you,
traveling across those battlefields
today,
meeting with soldiers, meeting
with families, meeting
with President Zelensky,
and then seeing the division
that we're seeing in Russia
over the last week, I'm more convinced
than ever
that the support that
the American people have provided,
the free world
has provided, is making it possible
for Ukraine
to reclaim their sovereignty, reclaim
their territory,
and and do a great service
to peace in the world.
Look, I think that
that repelling Russian aggression
is not just in the interests
of the people here in Kiev
and in Ukraine.
I think it's in our national interest
because I think it's in the interest
of the United States of America
and free countries around the world,
because by giving Ukraine
what they need to repel
the Russian invasion,
we're not only going to send a message
to Russia
that there are efforts
to redraw international lines
by force will not be tolerated.
But other nations like China
that's continuing to engage
in menacing military actions
across the Asia-Pacific
will get the message
that the free world will stand together
and precisely as we've done here
and watching the courageous
fighters here in Ukraine today,
it's been deeply inspiring.
We've just returned from the front lines
in southern Ukraine
and we saw the troops living camouflage
in the woods, literally every woods.
And then there be a farm field. Right.
But in that strip of woods,
their camouflage, their heavy equipment
and they're living there full time
Ukrainian troops,
they're dealing with
just fields
littered with mines
and grenades
where they're these little tiny wires
that no one would see
littering the woods.
Do you see an end in sight to a
war like this?
I do.
And and
when I met with President Zelensky today,
he said that
after a slow start
this spring, largely
owing to a very rainy season
that they've been seeing in recent weeks,
a steady advance
against those Russian lines.
And I have to tell you.
Remember, wars are fought
with soldiers,
with munitions and with morale.
And what I'm
sure you saw on the front lines today
and what I witnessed talking
not only to the leadership
of this country,
but to rank and file soldiers
was a genuine spirit.
They see the progress.
They see the fight they've put up.
I mean, it's amazing to think, Aaron.
Russia went from having the second
most powerful military in the world
to having the second
most powerful military in Ukraine.
I mean, Ukrainian fighters
have demonstrated
their toughness
equipped so well by the United States
and other allies that we've marshaled
some 50 countries around the world.
But I think the morale here in Ukraine
the progress
that I heard about from President
Zelensky today
and the division that we're seeing
of the leader of the Bognor group,
literally marching on Moscow
and now being exiled to Belarus and
and Vladimir Putin
literally flying troops
from those front lines back to Moscow
to reinforce
I mean,
I mean, that's
what happens when you engage in
an unprovoked act
of naked aggression
against your neighbor.
Innocent lives are lost.
Your soldiers lives are lost,
and you only sow
division in your country.
That's what's happening in Russia today.
And the morale
that you saw today
on those front lines,
I think, is going to carry them forward
to victory.
You mentioned Putin,
and of course, you've met him.
You dealt with him
when you were vice president.
Do you think he has full command
of his military right now?
I think it's an open question.
It is.
Now, the Wagner Group is a
specialty group.
We have some familiarity
with we American forces encountered
the Wagner Group in Syria back in 2018
when they moved against our forces.
And after being warned multiple times
the order was given and we took them out
without one American casualty.
But they are understood
to be
some of the most elite forces in Russia.
Now they've been dispersed.
They're being invited
back into the military.
But I did hear today
that they are decamping in Belarus,
along with their
their leader who is now in exile.
And I must just tell you that
we don't know what we don't know
about what's happening in Russia,
but that's always true about about Russia
and about Vladimir Putin.
But what I do know,
being here in Ukraine today,
is the resolve of Ukrainians
from President Zelensky
down to that
mother that I met in her pain
whose home had been rebuilt.
She was there when the rockets landed.
She lost a nephew in the attack,
but she never left. She rebuilt our home.
And she's she's she
and the Ukrainian people
are fighting for their freedom.
And with the support of the free world,
with America as a leader of free world,
I know they can win.
So there are a lot of reports.
And as you point out,
we don't know what we don't know about
what's going on in Moscow
that that is normal. But we don't know.
But there are reports about what
top Putin inner circle members
knew and did regarding promotion
to attempted rebellion.
Do you think it's possible
that Prigozhin had inside
help from key members
of Putin's inner circle?
I just I just wouldn't doubt it,
but I wouldn't know.
Yeah, I mean I mean, look,
I mean, to hear the way
Prigozhin is speaking about this
and talking about
how the children of the elites in Moscow
are putting cream on their face
while the
while the sons of the people are dying
in Ukraine suggests to me
that something is afoot in Russia
that sees that not only was this
an unjustified war.
Remember when Vladimir Putin launched
this invasion of Ukraine,
he said it'd be over in a week,
but he underestimated
the Ukrainian military
and candidly underestimated the resolve
of the free world.
But I
have to believe in my heart of hearts
that there are good and decent people
among the populists and in Russia
who are getting fed up
with this failed invasion,
with the loss of life.
And my hope is that
that's actually reached all the way
into the highest levels
of government as well.
And to that point,
the foreign minister here
in Ukraine earlier
this week told me
and his quote was,
Ferguson is just the first one to dare.
But I have no doubt
that others will follow.
Do you think that's what the U.S.
should be prepared for,
a Russia without Putin?
Is his power waning?
Well, I think the United States should
continue to be prepared
to provide the courageous military here
in Ukraine with the resources
they need to fight and win.
But I will say to you, Erin,
well,
while I
strongly support
American involvement here,
I heard again today
frustration about how slow
the Biden administration
has been in providing
that military support.
33 Abrams tanks were pledged in January,
and now they're being told
that they won't be here
until September of They've now
authorized allowing people
to be trained in F-16s,
but the United States continues
to hold back on allowing
said they're not going to get him,
he doesn't
think, till the beginning of next year.
Well, what good does that do?
My hope is that
this war is over
by the beginning of next year.
So you think the aid needs to come fast?
Look, I want to say I want to say
very sincerely.
President Biden said
in his last State of the Union address
that we're there as long as it takes.
I think it shouldn't take that long.
We're the most powerful nation on Earth.
We have
the most powerful military on earth.
And we ought to be providing them
with the tanks,
with the missiles,
with the aircraft
and with the what
the Ukrainian soldiers approve.
Those soldiers that you saw
on the frontline today. Yes.
You give them the means
to fight the Russians.
They're going to fight them to them,
and they're going to win a victory
not just for Ukraine,
but they're going to win a victory
for the free world.
And America
and nations across
the globe will be more secure
as a result.
You're clear on F-16s
where you stand sooner, sooner
rather than later.
But also, you mentioned missiles
attack them
Number one on the wish list here,
you think that should be.
Now, I do.
I heard about the
need for more mortar shells.
I mean, the
not getting into
the technical part of it, but
they need more ammunition.
And I think it's I think it's imperative
that we continue to provide that.
Look, we
we should never send American forces
into this fight.
The war here in Ukraine is not our war,
but freedom is our fight.
And since the days of the Reagan
administration, America's
always taken the position
that if you're willing to fight
America's enemies on your soil,
we'll give you the means
to fight them there
so we don't have to fight them here.
That's what this has been about
from the very beginning.
I know there's debate
both in my party
and around the country
about American involvement here,
but I really believe
that the majority of the American people
understand that
we are the leader of the free world
and standing for freedom and supporting
those that are fighting for their freedom
is always the American cause.
All of this in the context of,
of course,
the election
and your race for the White House.
We have obtained here at CNN
the audio tape of former
President Trump
talking about classified documents
found at Mar a Lago this week.
Here's what he said.
I just feel isn't that amazing?
Just totally wins my case, you know,
except it is like highly confidential.
There's
a secret info
that says, president,
I could have details.
You know, I can't, you know, but this is.
So this tape relates to just one
of the allegations,
right, in the indictment
that says that Trump not only obstructed,
but also justice,
but that he also disseminated
classified information.
Are you comfortable with his behavior
as you know it,
as you heard on that tape?
Well, what I can tell you, Erin, is that
handling classified
material is a very serious matter.
And
the allegations in the indictment
against a former president are serious,
but he does deserve his day in court.
Yes.
This shouldn't be litigated
in in the media.
Should be
it should be litigated in a court of law.
The president's entitled
to bring his defense.
I want to let that process work out.
Everybody's
entitled to a presumption of innocence.
So we'll
we'll stand on that
presumption of innocence.
But I don't want to diminish
the seriousness of these allegations
or diminish
the former president's
right to defend himself.
All right, Mr.
Vice President,
thank you very much
for your time here in Kiev.
Thank you. It's good to see you here.